हेलो गैस वेलकम तू अवर युटुब चैनल तो मेरा
नाम है आयुष पाठक और आप शुरू करते हैं हम
लोग नेटवर्क सीरीज का फोर्थ लेक्चर जिनको
नहीं पता है मैं यहां पर पहले युटुब पे
दिखा देता हूं
मैं ऑलरेडी नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का तीन
लेक्चर कर दिया था मैं वीडियो क्षेत्र में
ए जाता हूं अब मैं ऑलरेडी थ्री लेक्चर
कंप्लीट कर दिया सिक्योरिटी का ठीक है और
ये फोर्थ लेक्चर होने वाला है तो
स्टार्टिंग के तीन लेक्चर आपने नहीं देखें
हैं तो पहले उसको कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा वरना
इस लेक्चर में आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा कोई
चीज और जिन्होंने अगर थर्ड लेक्चर तक पूरा
फॉलो किया है बर्फ वालों की पोर्ट पर
वेडिंग को रिवीजन कर लेने क्योंकि हम लोग
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं आज वहीं से ठीक है
तो लास्ट लेक्चर मैंने आपको मतलब थोड़ी
समझाया था
एनजीओक्साइड कैसे करते हैं वो समझाया था
और क्या उसमें इशू आता है ठीक है राउटर से
कैसे करते हैं वो मैंने आपको बताया था
क्योंकि मेरा डॉक्टर सपोर्ट नहीं करता तो
मैं आपको डॉक्टर से दिखा नहीं सकता हूं
लेकिन मैंने आपको बताया था कॉन्सेप्ट क्या
होता है और राउटर पे जाके आप कैसे सेट कर
सकते हैं उन चीजों को तो मेरे पास आउट है
नहीं वो तो वो आज मैंने दिखाने वाला है
आपको और वो तरीका ऊतक कारगर भी नहीं होता
है इसलिए क्योंकि डॉक्टर से आप करते हैं
तो आपके पास पब्लिक आईपी राहत है जो वो
स्टेटिक पे राहत नहीं है डायनेमिक राहत है
मतलब आपका कुछ टाइम के बाद चेंज होता राहत
है तो वैसे में कितनी अच्छी नहीं लगी मतलब
आपका जो एक फिक्स आईटी किसी को देंगे तो
वो हमेशा परमानेंट नहीं रहेगा ना वो भी
चेंज हो जाएगी तो ऐसे में हमें ये कैसा
स्टेटिक सॉल्यूशन चाहिए होता है ठीक है थे
की हम एक किसी लिंक दें ठीक है किसी और को
तो दुनिया भर में कहानी से बेवकूफ कर सके
उसे लिंक को कभी भी जब भी हमारा सिस्टम ऑन
है मतलब जब भी हमारा सर्वर और सब कुछ
सेटअप है ऑन है यानी जब हम चाहते हैं तो
इस से रिंग से कोई भी कभी भी एक्सेस कर
सके जब हम चाहे तो वो लिंक डॉ हो जाए जब
हम चाहे तो वो लिंक अप हो जाए ठीक है पर
लिंक से रहेगा लिंग चेंज ना हो अब इसका
रेटिंग जगह इस्तेमाल होता है एक तो आप
अपना सर्वर किसी को मतलब लेना चाहते हैं
या कुछ भी आपका कम होगा ऐसा या फिर इसे आप
रिवर्स चार्ज सुनते हैं तो उसमें भी यही
कॉन्सेप्ट कम आता है ठीक है जब आप ऐसा कोई
मतलब जैसे जो बड़े लेवल पे कोई बैकग्राउंड
से ऐसी चीज होती है वो भी जब आप किसी को
भेजते हैं ठीक है ये सब इलीगल कम है लेकिन
अगर आप किसी मतलब ऑफिशल परपज के लिए अगर
ऐसा लुक करते हैं तो ऑफिशल से शुरू करते
हैं गवर्नमेंट ऑफिशल तो जब वो कोई
बैकग्राउंड भेजते हैं किसी सिस्टम पे तो
बैक डोर थ्री क्रैक करता है हैकर को ठीक
है तो जो भी कनेक्ट करेगा तो बैकग्राउंड
होना चाहिए कनेक्ट करेगा तो किस एड्रेस पे
रिचार्ज करेगा वो एड्रेस फिक्स होना चाहिए
ठीक है तो वही एड्रेस के लिए प्रोटीन सेट
करनी पड़ती है अगर आपकी फोटो फ्रेम सेट
नहीं रहेगी तो आपका जो एड्रेस है वो चेंज
होता रहेगा
और अगर आपने सर्टिफिकेट होगा तो एड्रेस
चेंज होता रहेगा स्टेटिक सॉल्यूशन चाहिए
ना तो इसलिए मैंने आपको लास्ट टाइम बताया
था की मैं एक ओपन वीपीएन और पोर्टमैन के
कांबिनेशन से आपको सीखने वाला हूं ठीक है
तो मैं आपको दिखता हूं वो चीज सबसे पहले
हम लोग यहां पर मोडल में ए जाते हैं
यहां पर आपको नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स वाला
मिल जाएगा
ओके मतलब कैसे कम कर रहा है वो नहीं
समझेंगे तो वो दिक्कत हो जाएगी दिक्कत
वाली बात हो जाएगी ये देखिए ये इंटरनेट है
ये राउटर है ये अंदर की डिवाइस है अब अगर
इंटरनेट बैठे किसी आदमी को राउटर से
कनेक्शन कनेक्ट किसी डिवाइस को एक्सेस
करना है तो आप हमें 440 का जरूर था
क्योंकि राउटर का करेगा इंटरनेट पर बैठा
हूं यूजर क्या करेगा राउटर की आईपी एड्रेस
पे पिंक करेगा की मेरा राउटर पे कोर्ट
नंबर 80 बताता हूं भाई क्या है कोई भी
फोटो जो हमने सेट किया होगा और उसे पोर्ट
के बाद ठीक है उसे पोर्ट की रिक्वेस्ट कौन
से ये अगर आउटडोर चलेगा की कौन सी डिवाइस
है तो वो पुटिंग से हम सेट करते हैं ठीक
है ताकि इंटरनेट बैठा कोई भी आदमी हमारे
मां चाहे किसी भी सर्वर को एक्सेस कर सके
ठीक है अब इसके लिए पहले हमें एक साइड
जाना पड़ेगा
ऐसी और भी साइड अवेलेबल होगी पर फिलहाल
मेरे अंदर मेरी वेबसाइट है इसमें आपको
रजिस्टर पे जाना है और यहां पे लॉगिन में
अपना सेट कर लेना है फिर ईमेल पासवर्ड
रजिस्ट्रेशन है ठीक है आपको रजिस्ट्रेशन
कर लेना है यहां पर फिर आपके ईमेल पे एक
लिंक आएगी
उससे पहले अपने अकाउंट को एक्टिवेट कर
लीजिएगा इसके बाद आपको लॉगिन पर जाना है
ठीक है तो मैं यहां पर लॉगिन कर लेट हूं
पहले मैंने लॉगिन कर लिया है इसमें अब
पहले यहां पर मैं कॉन्फ़िगरेशन में
ए जाना है यहां पर आपको क्रिएट न्यू
कंफीग्रेशन पर जाना है
नियम कुछ भी कर सकते हैं छोड़ देते हैं
ऐसे ही टाइप में आपको ओपन देना है
प्रोटोकॉल में आपको अपने यूजेस के हिसाब
से करना है तो फिलहाल मेरे को टच की जरूर
है तो मैं टीसीपी कर दे रहा हूं ठीक है
जेनरेट कर देता हूं इसको मैं
जेनरेट होने के बाद कुछ ऐसा आएगा आपके
सामने आपको यहां पर डाउनलोड क्लिक कर देना
है अब यहां पर ये देखिए फाइल डाउनलोड
बीपी ठीक है ये फाइल में डाउनलोड कर लिए
अब इसको क्लोज कर दीजिए अब देखिए यहां पर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन में आपने इस टाइम आपका एक
यहां पर जो है टीसीपी कंफीग्रेशन मिल चुका
है ये टीसीपी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन क्या करेगा
हमें ओपन वीपीएन के थ्रू इसके नेटवर्क में
कनेक्ट कराएगा तो इसके लिए हमें एक
सॉफ्टवेयर डाउनलोड करना पड़ेगा ओपन
विभिन्न नाम का ठीक है
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं इसको आराम से लेटेस्ट
वर्जन विंडोज के लिए तो ये विंडो 64 बीट
आप इंस्टॉल कर लीजिए मैंने इंस्टॉल रखा है
और फिर मुझे क्या करना है यहां पर पहले
ओपन यहां पर पहले मुझे एक सर्विस सेट करनी
है ठीक है इस पे कोई सर्विस रन हनी चाहिए
तो मैं जंप ओपन कर रहा हूं जंपर यहां पर
मैं इतना वेब सर्वर जो है चालू कर दे रहा
हूं तो पोर्ट टी पे मेरा वेब सर्विस चालू
हो चुका है इसको चेक कर लेते हैं अगर मैं
लोकल होस्ट करता हूं तो देखिए यहां पर
हेलो करके एक पे जा रहा है सिंपल सा ठीक
है ये पोर्ट 80 पर है दिखता हूं ये देखिए
450 पे ये पेज है ठीक है पॉजिटिव मेरा ये
सर्विस चालू हो गई है ठीक है अब मुझे क्या
करना है नैतिक रोशन
मैंने एक बार मुझे क्रिएट करना है मैं रूल
क्या किया
जाता हूं की मुझे टीसीपी रहने दीजिए इसको
भी कर सकते हैं आप ऐसे छोड़ दे रहा हूं
फिलहाल में आपको सिंपल यहां एक एंट्री कर
दी करनी है फोटो पीसी आपको अपने सिस्टम का
कौन सपोर्ट करना है
मुझे पोटती करना है मेरा एचटीटीपी सर्वर
अब मैं क्रिएट कर देता हूं सिंपल सा ठीक
है
कोई बन का साइन आता है जैसे यहां नोट
एक्टिव रीस्टार्ट वीपीएनसिएशन ठीक है अगर
यहां पर कोई बन का सेशन मतलब सर्किल उसमें
थोड़ा सा कुछ तो आप ट्राई करते जाइए आपका
कम ही नहीं करेगा तो वो कभी-कभी आपके जैसे
टेंपरेचर या फालतू कोई ईमेल उसे करते हैं
तब ऐसा होता है नहीं तो अगर आप इसका गलत
इस्तेमाल कोई करते हैं तब ऐसा होता है ठीक
है तो सुबह यही हुआ था की मैंने टेंपरेरी
इस्तेमाल कर लिया था जिसके वजह से बहुत
सुबह एक दिन पहले भी यही हुआ था मतलब
मैंने इतना डर ट्राई किया पर वो हो ही
नहीं राहत हूं मैं कंफ्यूज था की क क्यों
नहीं कर रहा है ठीक है ये छोटी-छोटी इशू
होती है क्योंकि ये सामने आपको लिख के
नहीं देते हैं पर से यहां पर बैंक का साइन
बन जाता है उसका मतलब ये है की आपका
अकाउंट जो है वो ब्लॉक है जैसे मैं आपको
चीज कम ही नहीं करेगा ठीक है तो ध्यान
रखिएगा आपका टाइम वेस्ट हो जाएगा वरना
क्योंकि मेरा हुआ था इसलिए मैंने आपको ऐसे
बता दिया ये चीज अब आपको क्या करना है
सर्विस
में हो रही है अब क्या करना है
ओपन करेंगे तो आपके सामने ऐसे कुछ सामने
से इंटर फेस नहीं आएगा ठीक है उसका एक
नोटिफिकेशन ए जाए तो आपको यहां पर आना है
ठीक है और यहां पर आपको ओपन का सिंबल मिल
जाएगा ये देखिए ओपन डी सिंबल इसे आपको
राइट क्लिक करना है ठीक है
कर देता हूं ठीक है चलिए इस तरीके से समझा
जाएगा
इंपोर्ट सेटिंग ऊपर दिखा रहा है ये सब
ऑप्शन आपको नहीं मिलेगा तो मैंने इंपोर्ट
पे आता हूं इंपोर्ट फाइल सिलेक्ट करता हूं
मैं ठीक है यहां पे डाउनलोड ए गया है
सामने ये वाली फाइल है हमारी तो मैंने
प्रीवियसली इसको ट्राई किया था पहले ठीक
है इसीलिए वो देर साड़ी दिखा रहा है पहले
से तो मैं इसको सिलेक्ट कर लेट हूं जो
हमने डाउनलोड किया था उसे टाइम वो सिलेक्ट
हो गया यहां पर अब वापस राइट क्लिक करेंगे
आप यहां पर आपको ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा वो वाला
भी और यहां पर आके आपको कनेक्ट पर चले
जाना है क्योंकि कनेक्ट कर देता हूं मैं
सामने स्त्री का वैल्यू खुलेगा
वेट करते हैं कनेक्ट कर रहा है ये कनेक्ट
कर चुका है अब इसको आप मेरे पास कर दीजिए
ठीक है कनेक्ट हो चुका है ये यहां पर चेक
कर सकते हैं ये यहां पर भी हो जाना चाहिए
यहां पर देखिए हो गया ग्रीन हो गया ग्रीन
हो गया मतलब कनेक्ट है आपको दिखेगा भी
कनेक्ट ठीक है तो ये कनेक्ट हो चुका है अब
देखिएगा जब ये जो बॉक्स बना हुआ है
रिफ्रेश करूंगा तो यहां पर टिक ग जाएगा एक
दो बार होता है ये देखिए टिक हो गया और ये
ग्रीन हो गया इसका मतलब ये कनेक्ट हो चुके
हैं तो आपको दो चीज आपको पहले यहां पर आना
है
ये नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी सर्च कर लीजिए आप ए
जाएगा मेरे ख्याल से
आपको डोमेन नेटवर्क वाला प्राइवेट नेटवर्क
वाला तीनों का ये जो फायर वाला है उसको
आपको डिसएबल कर देना है ठीक है तो मैंने
बैंड कर रखा है ऑलरेडी इसके अलावा कभी कभी
हो सकता है की आपका कम ना करें तो आपको
यहां पर ऐसे वाईफाई में आना है अपने ठीक
है
और यहां पर जाकर आपको सिलेक्ट कर देना है
की पब्लिक नेटवर्क या प्राइवेट नेटवर्क है
ठीक है उसका डिफरेंस पढ़ सकते हैं आप कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है
तो मेरा सर्विस जो है यहां पर चालू है ठीक
है फॉरवर्ड आपको यहां से बैंड कर देना है
वरना दिक्कत जरूर होगा आपको तो मेरा
सर्विस यहां पर चालू है सब कुछ रेडी है
ठीक है अब मेरा ये लिंक जो है क करना
चाहिए मैं आपको दिखता हूं ये लिंक जो है
आपको यहां से कॉपी करनी है
लिंक यहां पे कॉपी करना है आपको ठीक है
लिंक है ये पोर्ट है आगे अब यहां पर रखकर
मैं इसको पेस्ट कर देता हूं इंटर कर देता
हूं ये देखिए क्या होगा ये देखिए मेरी
वेबसाइट जो है ओपन हो चुकी है
दिखा देता हूं फिर से आपको
लोकल हॉस्पिटल
जो है एक्टिव रहेगी मतलब ये लिंक में किसी
को भेज सकता हूं तो ये जो है कम करेगी
अच्छे से कम करेगी एकदम मतलब आपको उसे
बंदे को आपके नेटवर्क में होने की कोई
जरूर नहीं है ठीक है तो हमने क्या किया
ईसप के इस पोर्ट को कहां से कनेक्ट किया
अपने लोकल सिस्टम के कोड नंबर 80 पे अपने
हिसाब से आप यहां पर चेंज कर सकते हैं की
आपको कनेक्ट करना है या कौन सा पोर्ट
कनेक्ट करना है जो भी आपके सर्विस हो रही
है असेंबली बैंड हो रही है जो भी रन हो
रही है फर्जी ज्यादा कम करेगा ये सिर्फ
वेबसाइट के लिए नहीं है ठीक है ना हर चीज
के लिए सिंपल सा पुटिंग हमने फिट कर दिया
उसका फायदा क्या है अब ये सिस्टम
रीस्टार्ट करूंगा बैंड करूं चाहे जो करूं
वीपीएन को डिस्क्राइब क्रैक करू मेरी ये
जो लिंक है ये तब तक से रहेगी जब तक मैं
यहां मैन्युअल ए के डिलीट बटन से ये
सेंचुरी को डिलीट नहीं करता हूं तब तक यही
से लिंक मेरे लिए एक्टिव रहेगी हमेशा ठीक
है अगर ये लिंक मैं किसी को भेजता हूं
क्योंकि कोर्ट में दाल के या फिर मैं साइड
ही भेजता हूं साइट इस लिंक को भेजता हूं
तो सामने वाला बंदे के लिए ये लिंक हमेशा
एक्टिव रहेगी जब तक मेरा सिस्टम चालू है
सिस्टम बैंड होगा लिंक बैंड होगी सिस्टम
चालू होगा लिंक वापस चालू हो जाएगी ये
नहीं की लिंक चेंज हो गई जैसा की होता है
एक्सचेंज राहत है
ये फ्री है ठीक है एंगरएजी भी फ्री है पर
दिक्कत करता है स्टार्टिंग में ठीक है ना
दिक्कत करता है तो वही बात है इसलिए मैंने
सब्सक्राइब का इस्तेमाल किया है ऐसी और भी
वो साइट है आप उनके बड़े में पता कर सकते
हैं पर अभी तक सबसे इफेक्टिव कम की है वो
ही वेबसाइट है वो आप समझ गए होंगे 440
कैसे कम करना है और कितनी तरीके है
राउटर्स तरीका है गो इस तरीके का है ये
तरीका है और ये तो मतलब जो नहीं है लेकिन
आपको एक कॉन्सेप्ट समझ ए जाएगा 414 का
इस्तेमाल कैसे करना है जनरल अपने किसी भी
उसे के लिए ठीक है तो इसको क्लोज कर देते
हैं अभी
इसको बैंड कर देते हैं सबको और मैं यहां
पर अपना कर देता हूं
मेरा बैंड हो गया है सर्वर को भी हम बैंड
कर देते हैं सर
व बैंड हो गया
था हमने पढ़ ली थी ठीक है एमजी ऑफ
प्रैक्टिकल देख लिया था आज आपने
प्रैक्टिकल देख लिया इसके बाद हमने क्या
किया
कैसे होता है या कम करता है और उसका
प्रैक्टिकल छोटा सा यहां पे था वो हम लिख
दिया था आज मैं क्या करना है वीपीएन
बेसिक्स ठीक है
ऑलरेडी आपको एक तरीके से उसे करके दिखा
दिया अब एक आपके लिए क्वेश्चन है की सोचिए
दो मिनट लीजिए और अच्छे सोचिए पॉज कर
दीजिए वीडियो में कहां किया
चलिए विपिन अपने उसे कहा की अभी आपने जो
ओपनिंग पे डाउनलोड किया था उसमें आपने
इस्तेमाल किया तो आपने क्या किया
ठीक है ये कम होता है वीपीएन का देखिए
विपिन का फिल्म क्या होता है वर्चुअल
प्राइवेट नेटवर्क और इसका देखिए उसे क्या
लिखा हुआ है डेट अल अलाउड डिवाइस सेपरेट
नेटवर्क ये देखिए ऑन डिवाइस ऑन सेपरेट
नेटवर्क्स तू कम्युनिकेट इन एन डेडीकेटेड
पाठ बिटवीन इ और इ अदर ओवर डी इंटरनेट
डिवाइस से कनेक्ट विद दिस चैनल फ्रॉम डियर
फ्रॉम डियर ऑन प्राइवेट नेटवर्क क्या मतलब
की इंटरनेट एक मजबूत जो की इंटरनेट है ठीक
है यहां पर दिया हुआ है आपका ये जो ग्रे
कलर है ठीक है इधर वाला जो ग्रे कलर
है सॉरी
ये एक नेटवर्क है और ये एक नेटवर्क है ठीक
है जो की दोनों इंटरेक्ट पे कनेक्ट है वो
तो ठीक है दोनों एक दूसरे को अच्छे नहीं
कर सकते हैं आम बात है लेकिन ये जो ब्लू
कलर से बना हुआ है नेटवर्क थ्री वीपीएन का
ये एक सेपरेट नेटवर्क है अब इसमें क्या हो
रहा है ये जो ये वाला जो है ठीक है ना
इसमें एक आउटर
है ठीक है और ये दूसरा नेटवर्क है जिसने
अगेन तीन डिवाइस कनेक्ट है और उसमें भी एक
डिवाइस जो है वो वीपीएन से भी कनेक्ट है
तो वीपीएन के थ्रू एक और नेटवर्क बन गया
है मतलब एक तो नेटवर्क की प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क है इधर वाला एक तो ये प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क है एक ये प्राइवेट नेटवर्क है
तीसरा नेटवर्क जो है वो ये है क्या नाम है
जो ब्लू से कनेक्ट है ठीक है ये ब्लू और
ये ब्लू तो ये ब्लू भले ही एक एशिया में
कहानी पे वो कहानी और ठीक है एक इंडिया
में पाकिस्तान में कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता
कितने भी दूर हूं ठीक है ये इंटरनेट के
थ्रू ऐसे कनेक्ट है ये एक्ट करेंगे जैसा
की एक ही नेटवर्क में है खाने का मतलब की
अगर ये बांदा अपनी दिखेगा अपने आईपी पे जो
कहना है नेटवर्क स्कैन करता है मतलब तो वो
इंटरनेट की पुरी तरीके से आपस में एक
कनेक्ट है ठीक है जैसे आप बीजेपी का
एग्जाम देते हैं तो उसमें भी होता है ठीक
है की आपको एक वीपीएन की फाइल दे दी जाति
है और ओपन से कनेक्ट हो जाते हैं तो उसे
दिन ऐसे आपको एड करवाता है जैसे की आप
उनके नेटवर्क में है ठीक है तो इससे क्या
होगा क्या आपको लगेगा की आप किसी कंपनी के
इंटरनल नेटवर्क में बैठे हुए हैं ठीक है
एकदम वैसे आपको फूल आएगी और वैसे ही आप सर
कम कर सकते हैं तो ये यही उसे होता है ठीक
है
वीपीनोलॉजी
ठीक है कुछ भी नई विपिन टेक्नोलॉजी
हो सकता है इंफेक्शन के लिए हो सकता है
ठीक है ये आपके जो एक्जिस्टिंग इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल फ्रेमवर्क है
इस तरीके से और टेक्नोलॉजी
टेक्नोलॉजी फ्रेम
पता होना चाहिए उसके बाद चीज नहीं आई
रहेगी
वो इंपॉर्टेंट है और इस चैनल नहीं होता है
केयर यार किसी के सामने गूगल कैसे करते
हैं तुमको दिक्कत नहीं होती है ठीक है फिर
से गलती हुई पोर्ट में पहले तो मैंने आपको
बताया था अगर मैं उसमें सलमान लोगों की
भाई मैं बताऊंगा क्या सोचेंगे लोग तो फिर
आपको भी कोई दिक्कत होगी तो आप भी सोचते र
जाएंगे टाइम वेस्ट होगा आपका भी मुझे गलती
हुई मैंने आपको बताया ठीक है तो आप गलती
नहीं होगी आपको ध्यान रहेगा वो चीज में तो
वही बात है
रूटिंग करता है बीच में ये हमने रिटर्न
में उसे दिन बात की थी वही चीज हमने बताया
था आपको स्विच कैसे कम करता है और इन
स्विच बिहार मैंने अमेरिका से आपको कुछ
नहीं बताया कुछ भी दो तरीके का होता है
लेयर तू और लेयर थ्री ठीक है तो इसकी सबसे
आईपीवी भी कम कर सकता है कैसे मतलब है की
बाय डिफॉल्टर स्विच को जैसे एक राउटर वाला
नेटवर्क में भी इंटरनेट क में तो में जो
डाटा ट्रांसफर होता है
थ्रू तो स्विच ऑफ भी अलग-अलग टाइप के आते
हैं ठीक है तो वो ध्यान रखिएगा आप लोग का
रहे हैं मेरा मतलब वही था हां यहां पे एक
अच्छा कॉन्सेप्ट है विलन वाला ठीक है
विलेन वर्चुअल लोकल नेटवर्क ठीक है ये एक
तरीके से सबने ठीक है सही है इसका
डेफिनेशन बताता हूं पहले आपको अलाउड
स्पेसिफिक नेटवर्क
ठीक है दिस स्प्लिट मिंस दे कैन जो
बेनिफिट फ्रॉम थिंग्स
मतलब क्या जैसे ये आउटर है ठीक है
ये डॉक्टर है आपका और ये आपका स्विच है
स्विच में आपने क्या किया इस स्विच में
मां लीजिए आपको दो तरीके की पोर्ट मिले
हुए हैं ठीक है मतलब अलग-अलग पोर्ट मिले
हुए हैं और दोनों पोर्ट एक दूसरे से
सेपरेट हैं मतलब आपका स्विच एक ही है और
इस स्विच में मैंने
किया दो एक तरफ पहले में तो दोनों अलग-अलग
नेटवर्क से होंगे ठीक है एक मां लीजिए एक
विलन तू है ये दोनों एक दूसरे से प्लेट है
एकदम सेपरेट है कोई मतलब नहीं है पर एक ही
दोनों ऑपरेट कर सकते हैं
डॉक्टर को आप अपना कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं ठीक
है लेकिन देर सारे उसमें सब नेटवर्क हो
सके ये डिफरेंस होता है
चलिए व्हाट इसे डी क पर डी एक्शन लेटर
राइटिंग
लेटर थ्री
स्टैटिसटिक्स साइड अटैक और एक्सपेरिमेंट
विद डी नेटवर्क सिम्युलेटर सिम्युलेटर
नीड्स तू टेक गेट फ्रॉम पॉइंट
तू कंप्यूटर
वन से कंप्यूटर
थिंक पैकेट है
कंप्यूटर
वन से कंप्यूटर करना है
से कनेक्ट है
कनेक्ट तू से एक कंप्यूटर कनेक्ट है ठीक
है अब इसको भेज देते हैं सेंड करते हैं
पैकेट को
अरे यार पुरी
ऑटोमेटिक
स्टार्ट होता है
अगर उसको नहीं पता है की कौन सी डिवाइस
कनेक्ट है मेरे पास कौन से पोर्ट पे तो
उसके लिए उसे हो गई ठीक है
फ्रेंडशिप के लिए वी कंप्यूटर
थ्री कहां पे है ठीक है तो क्या हुआ सीन
पैकेट मिल गया आपको कंप्यूटर को ठीक है
इसके बाद क्या होगा कंप्यूटर में रिसीवड
सीन है अब कंप्यूटर
वन को मिल गया ठीक है टीसी में होता है ये
इसके बाद यहां पर कंप्यूटर थ्री को एक मिल
गया मतलब कंप्यूटर बन जाए ठीक है वो एक
इमरजेंसी में ठीक है और वो कंप्यूटर थ्री
को मिल गया इसके बाद यहां पर डाटा सेंड
हुआ होगा मेरे ख्याल से हां सेंडिंग पैकेट
भी पैकेट
जो रिसीव हो गया और आपका कम जो है खत्म हो
गया यही था यहां पर पता नहीं ये अच्छा
राहत है आपको ये काफी ज्यादा डायग्रामेटिक
रिप्रेजेंटेशन दे देता है इसको आप आराम से
वीडियो धीरे करके खुद से ट्राई कर सकते
हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हो में हैंड चेक
एंट्रीज आर देवर इन डी नेटवर्क लॉक
हो गया है
तो ठीक है
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है वीडियो इसलिए बनाई
जा रही है इनके पास नहीं है वो भी समझ सके
ठीक है
पहले मैंने कभी किया होगा इसको एक्चुअली
इनफॉरमेशन
फंडामेंटल्स के बाद अब हम लोग आगे क्या
पढ़ने वाले हैं लेकिन फिलहाल अभी हम लोग
ये नहीं करने वाले हैं अभी हम लोग को
थोड़ा और चीज है समझ नहीं बाकी है तो कुछ
मैं करके भी दिखाने वाला आपको प्रैक्टिकल
ठीक है सबसे पहले मैं आपको एक फाइल बताता
हूं एक चीज का यहां पर उसको फाइल खत्म
आपको
[संगीत]
टेबल तू डाउनलोड ठीक है
ये राउंड 865 बी की है आपको इसमें डाउनलोड
कर लेना है ठीक है ना फिलहाल मैं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं क्योंकि मेरे पास
डाउनलोड पड़ी हुई है डाउनलोड करने के बाद
आपको चेक कर लेना है ठीक है जैसे आप काली
की जो होती है ना एमवेयर इमेज जैसे वो
एकदम से वैसे ये भी इंस्टॉल होगी ठीक है
आपको एक्सट्रैक्ट करना है यहां पर आना है
माइक कंप्यूटर पे यहां पर
ठीक है आपको न्यू बजा के फाइल में जाके
यहां पर इंपोर्ट करके ठीक है आपको आराम से
न्यू वर्जन
है ये सेट करना है उसको स्टार्ट कर देते
हैं
मैं आपको यह क्यों बता रहा हूं मैं बताता
हूं की यह बीच में कहां ए गया ठीक है ये
इसलिए ए गया क्योंकि बहुत साड़ी ऐसी भी हम
नेटवर्क कैसे फंडामेंटल तो पढ़ लिया आपने
जैसे कम करता है क्योंकि मॉडल था वो
फंडामेंटल करता है की मतलब बेसिक नेटवर्क
क्या होता है कैसे कम करता है उसमें
टर्म्स क्या होते हैं और चीज क्या होती है
थर्मोमीटर टेक्निक क्या होते हैं वो मैं
समझ लिया अब हम इसको धीरे-धीरे एक्सप्लेन
पे आएंगे मतलब उसमें एनीमेशन कैसे करना है
इनफॉरमेशन कैसे करनी है कैसे करना है तो
उसके लिए कई जगह हमें इसका इस्तेमाल
करेंगे हम ठीक है मतलब इसको ऐसे टारगेट
इस्तेमाल करेंगे हम क्योंकि हम 12 से एक
सिस्टम पे डायरेक्ट तो कर नहीं सकते हैं
जितने भी जैसे कई सारे इमीग्रेशन करना
होगा तो वो हम इस पे करेंगे की एक खास
करके जाएगा बहुत सारे सर्विसेज को कैसे
एक्सपर्ट किया जाता है कैसे एक्सपर्ट से
किया जाता है वो सब चीज हम लोग इसमें करने
वाले हैं ठीक है
जितना ट्रैक में दिया हुआ है वो तो हम
करेंगे उसके अलावा के साथ-साथ जितनी
जहां-जहां मुझे जरूर लगता है की यहां मुझे
अपने सेट को जरूर हर जगह में अपना चीज
यहां पर एड कर देता हूं सामने इसलिए मैंने
आपको दिखा दिया है की हम इसका इस्तेमाल
करेंगे तो आपको इंस्टॉल कैसे करना है उसे
कैसे करना है आपको पता होना चाहिए ठीक है
या फिर इस तरीके से आपके सामने खुला जाएगा
यहां पर इसका अमेरिका तो वो भी दिया होगा
लॉगिन की एस अकादमी
हो जाएंगे ठीक है
सबको लॉगिन नहीं करना है बेसिकली ये तो
ऐसा अप लॉगिन
रहेगा मतलब अपने सिस्टम से ठीक है जैसे हम
लोग ये पढ़ने वाले हैं इसको यहां पर
एग्जिट कर देता हूं रोको कर दिया मैंने और
इसको हम लोग शुरू डॉ कर देते हैं चलिए तो
मैं टेबल को मैंने क्लोज कर दिया है ठीक
है ये पक्का सेटअप कर लीजिएगा क्योंकि
हमने काफी कम करने वाले हैं अब मैं आपको
इसी बता देता हूं मैं आपको ये चीज र गया
था ठीक है जो मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकल दिखा
रहा था पहले अपना काली चालू कर लेट हूं
ठीक है तो अभी तो अपने समझ लिया होगा कैसे
कम करती है अच्छे से प्रैक्टिकल मैंने
लिया अब वही चीज जो की हमने वीपीएन कॉल
सभी पढ़ लिया है ठीक है तो आपको ओपन यू
कैन जो है उसको कैसे इस्तेमाल
स्वीटी देते हैं उसका मेरे को पता रहा हूं
आपको ठीक है इसमें भी आपको ऐसे ही मतलब
इंगेजमेंट मिल जाता है की आपका कंपनी है
ऐसे करना है और आपको एक ओपन फाइल मिल जाति
है ठीक है नेटवर्क कनेक्ट करना होता है तो
वो आपको भजन करना होगा आपको कॉपी में भी
करना पद सकता है ठीक है तो लिंक एक्सप्रेस
कैसे करना है वो भी आपको दे रहा हूं मैं
अच्छे से मैं यहां पर ओपन करता हूं काली
को 15 फाइल हमने डाउनलोड कर लिया ऑलरेडी
मतलब पॉर्न पे जो कम है वो तो ऐसे ही
रहेगा ठीक है विंडोज हमने क्या किया था बस
एक फाइबर में से किया था ओपन चालू करो
कनेक्शन किया था वही चीज है लेकिन कैसे
रहेगी आपको दिखता हूं एक बार करके अच्छे
से कोई डाउट हो जाइए
इस तरीके से और भी जहां तक मुझे जरूर
पड़ेगी मतलब की आपको लगेगा मुझे की ऐसे
ऐसे आपको फाइल ऑन करनी है वो आपको पहले भी
भेज दूंगा आपको इनको दिक्कत ना हो लेकिन
और कोई अगर आपको दिक्कत हो तो फिर बताना
है अगर कोई कॉन्सेप्ट नहीं ए रहा है कोई
इशू हो रही है ग रहा है की नहीं है तो फिर
आप उसको बताइए कमेंट में देखते हैं
क्योंकि ऐसा भी होता है
ठीक है डिमांड है जैसे मैंने बताया था
वीडियो वाला भूल गया था आपको लगता है पूछ
लीजिए ठीक है उसमें कोई रजिस्ट्रेशन नहीं
चलिए तो पहले मैं अपनी फाइल को यहां पर
मूव कर लेट हूं ठीक नहीं कर देते हैं
आपको पहले मतलब जहां भी आपका जो है फाइल
वहां पर फाइल राखी हुई है ठीक है ये अलग
तरीके से ठीक है मैंने ये कॉपी पेन है
दूसरी है तो मैं आपको दिखता हूं आपको
लिखना है ओपन ठीक है ओपन
वीपीएन दास दास कनफ्लिक्ट और फिर आपको
अपनी वो वीपीएन जो फाइल है ये करके आपको
सिंपल इंटर कर देना है ठीक है इंटर कर
देता हूं वेट करना है आपको
यहां पर नया इंटरफेस जो है बन गया| तन
जीरो ठीक है तन जीरो जो भी कई है इसको आप
यहां पर मुझे जो आईपीएस साइन हुआ है इनकी
नेटवर्क मतलब ट्राई सॉरी ट्राई मैं का रहा
हूं ओपन विपिन के नेटवर्क में ठीक है वो
ये वाला है अब इसको जहां कनेक्ट करें मतलब
करते हैं तो यहां पे जो आपका आईपी होगा वो
आपका वो आईपीओ का जो मशीन हो सकता है खाने
का मतलब जैसे आपका कोई लैब चालू करते हैं
ठीक है ना अभी तो हम बॉक्स में भी पढ़ रहे
हैं जो आप सिटी के अंदर आएंगे जब हम यहां
पे तो आज मैं आपको ये सिस्टम ऑन करते हैं
ठीक है मतलब मशीन तो आप ऐसे अटैक कर आपका
आईपी एड्रेस ये राहत है तो अगर आपको रिवर
सेल लेना है तो मैंने आपको कोई एक बंदर
वीडियो मिलती है और वहां फ्री में जाके
दाल देते हैं
तो आपसे अगर आपको अपना आईडी डालना होगा ये
वाला भी डालेंगे
अब अपना डॉक्टर का प्राइवेट डालेंगे ना आप
अपना पूरी डालेंगे ठीक है अब कौन सा आईपी
डालेंगे ये वाला जहां पर आपको किसने दिया
है ओपन अप में दिया है कलेक्शन के बाद ठीक
है अगर यही कनेक्शन है बैंड कर देता हूं
मतलब की तब मैं कनेक्ट है ठीक है सुबह
कंट्रोल देता हूं तो अगर मैं आपको दिखता
हूं मुझे आईपी कॉन्फ़िग का आउटपुट ये
देखिए दो इंटीरियर है आईटी इसे जीरो
इंटरफेस था वो चला गया तो यही इंटरफेस एन
ऐसी सब तो आप क्लियर यस विदाउट होना ही
चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से डिटेल में बात की थी
तो इस तरीके से ओपनिंग पी का इस्तेमाल
करके पैक कर सकते हैं ठीक है ना क्लियर हो
गया होगा
चलिए
आपको बता देता हूं आपने सर्विस अपाचे तू
ठीक है
अपाचे तू स्टार्ट ठीक है
इसको इंटर कर देंगे आप
ठीक है
स्टार्ट
कर सकते हैं हम लोग इस तरीके से ठीक है
सर्विस स्टार्ट से और जो अपाचे
www.html राहत है ठीक है
आपकी जो भी वेबसाइट की फाइल है वहां पर
अपलोड कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो ऐसे तो
नॉर्मली जो वेबसाइट मतलब ये मैंने आपको
इसलिए बता दिया अच्छे से इसमें दीप उसके
मतलब विंडोज के लिए उसके लिए क्योंकि बहुत
साड़ी ऐसी साइड होती है ना देखो होस्ट
करने होती है अपने पास ये कुछ टाइम के लिए
होती है तो ऐसे में अब अपने सिस्टम कर
सकते हैं की आपको सिस्टम
को किसी को भी अवेलेबल कर सकते हैं कुछ
टाइम के लिए समझ गए होंगे आप सर मतलब मेरा
ठीक है कैसे कैसे कम करना है
तो यहां पर विंडोज के लिए भी विंडोज में
भी एक तो आप का स्वागत कर सकते हैं दूसरा
अगर आपको छोटा मोटा फाइल ट्रांसफर करना है
इसमें फोल्डर में ए गया ठीक है
मैं अगर करता हूं|
http.saver ये एक मोडल होता है इसको मैं
जैसे ही इंटर करूंगा मेरा एक एचटीटीपी
सर्वर एक्टिव हो जाएगा अभी सर्वर कहां
एक्टिव है किसी भी ये कलम का मतलब कोई भी
आईपी ठीक है और पोर्ट नंबर 8000 पे मतलब
ये सिस्टम के जितने भी इंटरफेस है जितनी
भी आईपीएल है उनमें से कोई भी आईपी और
पोर्ट नंबर 8000 तो अगर ब्राउज़र में
जाऊंगा अपने और यहां पर मैं ओपन करता हूं
लोकल ठीक है और एक बार 8000 है तो मुझे
लिखना पड़ेगा क्योंकि 80 डिफॉल्ट होता है
या फिर 434 होता है अगर 8000 इंटर करता
हूं यहां पर ये देखिए इस टाइप के बन जाएगा
अपने यहां पे कोई भी फाइल सिलेक्ट करके
बता दिया मैंने आपको साड़ी चीज बता दे रहा
हूं पहले ठीक है जो हम आगे उसे करने वाले
हैं कहानी ना कहानी से किसी ना किसी मध्य
से ठीक है तो कहानी भी उसे करेंगे मतलब
सिक्योरिटी इसका मैं सवाल करूंगा इसलिए
मैं आपको अभी सर्च करता हूं यही आपके लिए
जरूरी है ठीक है
कैसे उसमें हमने
लाइव हो डिस्कवरी की थी ठीक है फोर्थ खाने
का मुझे याद नहीं बताया था की नहीं
क्योंकि वो आगे पढ़ना ये भी अच्छे से
गुड्स कैनिंग को रिटर्न पढ़ेंगे इसमें
बढ़िया से ठीक है सारे जो टेक्निक्स होते
हैं वो भी लेकिन जितने भी है वो कंप्यूटर
है
आपके लिए मैंने आपको बताया था की क्या नाम
है मैंने विंडोज में दिखाए था क्योंकि
विंडोज में मैंने यहां पर डाउनलोड
ठीक है इसको
मेरे वीडियो में कोई कम डिजाइन कमांड
प्रॉब्लम
कहते हैं ये रहा आपको सामने जन्नत जीव आए
ठीक है और लाइनर पर आएगा ही कर लेना
आपको एन मैप से
हमने पता ही है ठीक है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है इसमें लेकिन मैं आपको इसका दिखता हूं आ
वो ठीक है ग्राफिकल वाला ये देखिए जैन अप
इसका प्रिंट करेंगे ऐसे तो ये आपके सामने
खुला जाएगा देखिए इस तरीके से यहां पर
आपका इजी कम किया जाता है आपको सिर्फ
टारगेट लिखना है यहां पर आप टारगेट लिखिए
और कुछ नहीं लिखना है यहां पर जितनी भी
कमांड रहेगी अपना दाल देगा और आपको सामने
दिखा देगा ठीक है तो मां लीजिए टारगेट में
मां लीजिए पुरी लिस्ट दे देता हूं अपना
वीडियो देख लेट हूं मैं क्या है
मैं अपने पूरे नेटवर्क को देखा हूं
ये मेरा
192163 और 45 ठीक है
[संगीत]
मेरे डिवाइस कनेक्ट नहीं है मेरे ख्याल से
होने वाले हैं
स्कैन जो है वो स्टार्ट हो चुका है
मतलब की ठीक है
पॉइंट मतलब
खोल देता हूं ये आप सेटिंग में जाकर फीचर
कर सकते हैं इसको ये तरीके से होता है
बेसिक बेसिक चीज है
ठीक है तो यहां पर भी आप ऐसे ही बेसिक
टूल्स का इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं
जरूर थी मैंने आपको साड़ी चीज बता दी है
ठीक है तो इसको भी क्लियर बहुत लंबा ही
रखेंगे इसी बड़े में पूरा नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन शुरू करने वाले हैं क्या चीज है
यहां शुरू करेंगे दोनों स्ट्रक्चर
ठीक है शुरू करेंगे और आगे धीरे-धीरे हम
जो है बढ़ते जाएंगे आपको काफी कुछ मालूम
हो जाएगा नेटवर्क के बड़े में और इनके बीच
में ही हमें जहां जरूर होगी मटर पूरा कम
करेंगे अच्छे से लंबी हो गई लेकिन बहुत
बढ़िया होंगे ठीक है जरूर होगी आपको मैं
कुछ भी कार्टून नहीं मतलब अगर लंबी आयु
होने दीजिए अगर पसंद ए रही है चलती रहेगी
लेकिन कर सब कुछ होगा ठीक है दिक्कत आप
लोगों को कोई नहीं होगा इसमें तो आज की जो
है कहानी पे और करते हैं उसके लिए थैंक यू
और अगर ये वीडियो आज अपलोड हो रही है तो
टीचर्स दे की आपको हार्दिक शुभकामनाएं ठीक
है ना आज के लिए वीडियो को और फिर मैंने
कंटिन्यू करेंगे सारे करेंगे जितने पुराने
थे वो भी अगर आपने नहीं किया हैं और इसको
भी आपको पूरा टास्क कंप्लीट करना है ठीक
है अब शेर कर सकते हैं करिए नहीं कर सकते
हैं तो आप देखिए मैंने कंप्लीट किया है
उससे हमें मोटिवेशन मिलता है ठीक है ना
करते हैं थैंक्स पर वॉच